[Music]
what I tried to do was take away all my
opponent
Army and
then I figured whatever I had left I
would try to Checkmate them with which
was a pretty good thing right figured
that I would try to Checkmate my
opponent only after I captured
everything I possibly could of my
opponent sometimes the game went
excessively WR long let's say that I did
really
good and I actually won the game which
was a miracle I mean miracles happen I
sometimes sometimes it's like you know
once on a full moon I once won a chess
game and
um I've been watching games of the club
played by players who aren't that
experienced and so they try to do the
same technique as me take away
everything of their opponents and they
don't see checkmating patterns so the
goal of Chess is to Checkmate our
opponent's king fair enough so let's
learn some of the most typical uh
checkmating patterns so in this position
we would say from a material count 1 two
3 one two 3 the pawns are even black has
two Rooks which are worth 10 as we know
five each versus a queen which is worth
nine and yet white has a forced
checkmating pattern here do you all know
this
pattern not everybody I know Charlie
does I know he do
so the checkmating pattern is we're
looking at Black's king for a moment
we're thinking to ourselves well how
could we set up a Checkmate we notice
that our Queen is pretty close but the
Queen by
itself can't deliver Checkmate in other
words if we play Queen takes G7 check
and say check mate what if our opponent
disagrees with us he goes no I'll just
take your Queen oops we just lost our
Queen for a pawn ah so we start to think
what else besides our Queen can attack
this Pawn young
lady
correct precisely so this in fact sets
up what we call a checkmating pattern
and it's one of the most uh common types
of checkmating pattern there is so our
threat is to play now Queen takes G7
check and mate because the king cannot
capture the Queen the queen is protected
by the pawn so black has no choice he
has to advance
Pawn now what can we do now what can we
do young man Queen H6 Queen H6 so this
move white slides his Queen to the H6
square and black to his horror
realizes that there is no way that he
can prevent our next move we can he can
move his Rook if he likes he can move
this Rook if he likes but he cannot
Escape Queen G7 check and mate it's one
of the most common uh checkmating
patterns and what I did when I was a kid
is I had what I call my Arsenal yeah
what I mean by that is I had a number of
checkmating patterns excuse me a number
of checkmating patterns that that I
became familiar with so I put them in my
arsenal of checkmating patterns so this
is one of the most common checkmating
patterns let me change for a moment and
I'm taking the pawn that helped us make
the check making pattern away from the
board you don't have it
anymore instead what I'm going to do is
I'm going to put a bishop on the E7
square and now
when I was young without a doubt you
know what I would do what take the
absolutely I would take that rook and
I'd be very happy because I would say my
Bishop is worth three your Rook is worth
five that trades in my favor and yet
capturing The Rook is the wrong move
instead young men in the blue
yes
absolutely a moment ago we had a pawn
and that pawn we we call this it pierced
it
pierced a moment ago you see this Pawn
Shield by Black's King that pawn
Shield's really really good but when we
put a Pawn on F6 we pierced the pawn
shield with the bishop we do the same
thing once again in this position we are
threatening Queen G7 captures Queen T
captures G7 check and made black is not
allowed to capture our Bishop because
that would place his King in the direct
line of fire of White's Queen so black
has to play the move G6 and we
play jackm we play Queen to H6 we slide
just as we did with the pawn so the
bishop
began to be as good as the pawn the
bishop protects the pawn on
E6 the bishop protects the queen on G7
our next move is going to play Queen
takes
G7 now I'm going to uh change the
position for a moment the last move by
white is he's going to play Queen here
threatening a checkmate
okay but black has a way of Defending
his G7 Square how young
man correct not only moving the Knight
to F5 protects the G7 Checkmate but
oops it also threatens the queen oh dear
wh's in trouble right White's in trouble
what could white do to create a
checkmating pattern young man Queen
takes H whoa did you see this move Queen
takes H7 check to the but that's a
terrible move he'll just take our Queen
then we're
dead white has to resign
Charlie
Rook to H1 check to the
king now I understand the power of the
bishop the bishop reaches to the h8
square I'm going to block the check
young
man Rook takes H6
check now I have no choice I have to
drop back with my
king and young
man
Rook to h8
Checkmate so this checkmating pattern we
the black king cannot take the Rook The
Rook is protected by the bishop the
black king cannot move to G7 that square
is protected by the white bishop and the
black king cannot move to F7 because
that square is occupied by his Pawn so
this checkmating p pattern has a very
important setup notice that the bishop
is on the long diagonal and it protects
the HH Square now what
we determined a moment ago is in this
position white played the move Queen
H6 and then this move Queen H6 was
answered by Knight F5 protecting the
mate
threat
did white need to play Queen H7 Queen
H6 Charlie no no
why
right
yeah exactly he didn't need to delay
sacrificing his Queen he could have done
it at once some of you have seen
these problems before you're probably
very familiar with them but all they are
are patterns patterns that recur time
and time and time again and they come
from all kinds of openings and all kinds
of
positions
so
black in this position
he sees that his Pawn on C3 protects the
square
B2 he moves with his Queen here
threatening Checkmate on B2 as well as
Checkmate on A1 thanks to the protection
of the
Rook Queen E7 to A3 was played by black
and white realizes he's dead he's dead
he's he's going to get checkmated either
on the B2 square or the A2
Square so white could resign white could
give it up congratulate his opponent but
white has a desperate idea what's his
idea Rook to h8
check what's that is that just is that
just a check and then we get to resign
what are we doing we going going to take
the
rook and now yes Queen to
H5 Queen to
H5
check where can the king go only one
square King to G8 and now we have a
Checkmate do you guys all see the
Checkmate the pawn on
G6 attacks the F7 Square as well as the
H H7 Square sare so that we could play
the move Queen H7 Checkmate so this
pattern with the a moment ago our Pawn
was on F6 and we were checkmating on G7
with this pattern our Pawn is on G6 and
we're checkmating on H7 let's go back a
moment black did not see this Rook
check okay black did not see this Rook
check uh I need a
queen had he seen that Rook check he
himself would have what should black
have done what should black have done
this move actually looks like it's
winning but as we've just seen a moment
ago it loses the game young
man should have played rookie black
should have played Rook A1
check do you see why white has no option
he has to take the Rook the B2 square is
protected by the pawn on C3 we take the
rook and now it's Black's turn to
deliver Checkmate how could black
deliver Checkmate young lady
yes a
A3 A3 Queen checks the King on A1 white
has no choice he has to move his King to
B1 and now our familiar checkmating
pattern
Queen check and mate indeed and that
check mating pattern just as we saw with
the pawn on F6 I would put that in my
little chess scrapbook and I would say
okay now now I have two checkmating
patterns with a queen and a pawn as well
as a checkmating pattern with a rook and
a bishop or a queen and a
bishop and these checkmating patterns
come from all types of
positions so this of course is not a
checkmating pattern there's no there's
no Checkmate Black's King is very very
solid it has this beautiful Shield of
ponds that are standing there protect
protecting Black's
King on the other hand black has two
pawns what we call two pass pawns on the
queen side and those pawns are rushing
down the board and they're going to try
to make a queen now when I was a
beginning player I again I wanted to
capture all my opponent pieces take them
off the board and only when I had
captured everything would I try to win
the game so in this position I would
only consider the moves Rook takes I win
a pawn I'm so
happy or I would consider the move
Knight takes B8 winning a rook I'm so
happy right and I'd Overlook that in
fact there is a checkmating pattern
here white has a checkmating
pattern does anybody know the
checkmating pattern
Charlie but what about King
G6 oh King
G6 there's no Checkmate what Charlie
said is if the king went back to G8 we
have a Knight smothered mate the black
king you see that Knight smother mate
the black king so let's go
back to this position young
man7 Knight to E7 check now notice after
the Knight comes to E7 check the king is
kind of Trapped behind his own pawns he
can't capture his own pawns The Rook
stops his King from moving to
f8 the only move is King h8 and now
takes H now Queen takes H7 check King
takes r h Rook H3 Checkmate
wow how cool was that the Rook attacks
the black king the black king can the
black king to move to G6 no because of
the Knight on E7 correct the Knight on
E7 protects the G8 as well as the G6
squares Black's King is checkm I would
never not in a million years have
thought of this combination myself when
I was starting chess I was trying to
capture all of my opponents pieces not
give up my queen oh
my I I have this story and it's one of
my favorite stories when I was starting
to play chess I was very lucky I had a
chess teacher and his name was Jeffrey
Parsons and he was a really strong
player by the United States Chess
Federation uh standards he had a
1,900 rating how many of you know what a
1,900 rating means yeah he was what we
call a Class A player and he was also a
very very wonderful teacher this pattern
was my absolute favorite I love this
pattern and Jeffrey gave me this problem
and he said to me that I had the Whit's
pieces and that I could win the
game and I thought that's impossible I
can't win the
game black has a rook and a rook two
Rooks I have no
Rooks and black is threatening to
capture my
knight and I will be down a
rook if I capture the queen what's wrong
with that move young
man yes cuz the Rooks can Capt you The
Rook could capture my queen and an
entirely different Checkmate occurs this
is called the back rank Checkmate The
Rook attacks White's King but White's
King can't move to any squares cuz he's
blocked by his own Pawn Shield why does
checkm it there's a book called Bobby
fiser teaches chess how many of you have
seen that book okay the entire book I
kid you not has one trick and one trick
only in the entire book and that's the
trick that we see on the board the back
rank Checkmate Bobby fiser thought the
back ranked Checkmate pattern was so
important he devoted an entire book to
it when I read the book I thought to
myself this guy Bobby fiser is the world
champion he's a one-trick pony all he
knows is the back ring Checkmate I could
beat him so we go back to this
position
and again Jeffrey said no Yasser you
have a winning
combination and I thought okay of course
of course I will play Queen to D5
checking the black king on G8 the black
king cannot move to f8
why Checkmate on the move with Queen on
D5 to F7 check to the king the king
can't go any and the King can't capture
the queen because the Knight protects
the queen so this would be Checkmate and
I'd add this to my arsenal of
checkmating
patterns but of course black will not
move his King to f8 instead he will move
it to
h8 young man and then they move
absolutely I would play okay now by the
way keep in mind I was very clever I saw
that black Black's threat is to
Checkmate me I'm still in the back rank
checkmating pattern so everything I do
has to be with check so of course I
understood that I had to play Knight to
F7 check to the black king Black's King
has no choice and now because I want to
grab
material oh I was so happy taking my
opponent's pieces I can't tell you I
would take the Rook with check how many
of you think this is a good move winning
a rook for
free yes that's what I would do I would
take that Rook with check and he's in
check he cannot play here because of
that very same checkmating pattern as
before the Knight protects the queen
Checkmate so black has to go here now
what did I
do how oh
oh and remember I'm facing back rank
check mate black is still threatening
his Checkmate furthermore he's
threatening to capture my knight
what of course that's exactly what I did
he moved his King
back
Charlie double Che Knight H6 double
check now the king is under attack from
the Knight so that's a check from the
Knight but the check the queen also
checks the the King on G8 so that's why
we call this situation a double check
again and again and again King f8 is a
bad move as that allows us
Checkmate so he my opponent would have
to move his King to a J yes young
man
sorry okay so now what can I do yes you
move your um Queen to G8 okay Queen to
G8 wow that's a sophisticated move but I
don't get it I cannot take the the queen
with my king because the Queen's
protected by the Knight so so I'll take
your queen with my
queen ooh thank you very much and I'm
threatening your KN but more importantly
I still have the
dramatic back rank Checkmate for black I
blew
it let me say right away that I was
unable to solve this problem I I I tried
everything I could all kinds of checks
and everything I could and I couldn't
win the
game it was terrible I failed so then I
asked Jeffrey please show me the
solution what did I get
wrong and I got the first move right
check I got the second move right
check here's where I got the third move
wrong I took the
Rook that was I was so happy to take the
Rook but you guys have probably solved
the Checkmate by now there's the Knight
H6 double
check King moves over to
h8
now check do you see the difference a
moment ago we captured The Rook with
with the queen now we're capturing The
Rook how what can black do what can
black do yes young
manen take the queen and then what does
again white is facing now not just once
but twice back rank mate
now smothered
Checkmate oh
wow I was so happy I was so happy with
this mother Checkmate I couldn't contain
my excitement and I ran home and my mom
was uh washing the dishes so I dragged
my mom out of the kitchen brought her to
the dining room table I set this up I
set up the problem I showed her the
double check with the Knight and I S
showed her the smothered mate I was so
excited do you know what my mom said to
me she said very good Yasser can I go
back and wash the dishes now she didn't
get it this was really really pretty I
sacrificed my queen to force a check
made and that was uh that was really the
start of how I got to be very excited
about Chess is because I started to
learn how to create checkmating patterns
and I would look for all of these
patterns all of these different ways of
checkmating my opponent one of the one
of
the ones that I really messed up on this
happened to
me this happened to me I was black in a
tournament game it was one of my first
tournament games I ever
played in fact what happened was in my
first tournament ever it was the
1973 SN homish County open in SN homish
Washington I come from Seattle and as
you guys know all good things come from
Seattle not
well that's a it's a bad
sign so I had the black pieces in a
situation like this and in the first day
which was Saturday I played three games
and I lost all three of my games ah
brutal
brutal on Sunday I came back and it A
Miracle of Miracles I won two games so
my score was two wins and three
losses and uh they gave me a prize I won
a prize a trophy I was the best player
under the age of 16 years old and I got
a trophy for that but did you know I was
the only only player under 16 years old
so even if I lost all my games I would
have won the
trophy so here what I did is I captured
the
Knight and can you see a checkmating
pattern for White young man in the
blue
Rook d8 check now is this a back rank
Checkmate why not because instead of a
there's a and so what does that
mean I can block black can block and I
was black and I blocked the check to my
king by putting my Bishop in the way and
I thought the position was e St Stevens
rook and Bishop versus rook and Bishop
three pawns versus three pawns I was
hoping to make a draw but I couldn't why
because black white can play Bishop to
H6 Bishop to
H6 and I felt so physically
helpless I can't do anything about Rook
captures like I could move my rook and
he would take my rook and then I could
move a pawn but then white has a
Checkmate how
Charlie
Checkmate notice that in this pattern
before we had a pattern that looked like
this remember this
pattern where our Bishop supported our
rook and we checkmated on h8 well now we
have a different
pattern now we have the bishop on
H6 supporting our
rops our Rook so after a move like F5
Rook takes f8 is check mate the king
can't take the Rook because it's
protected by the bishop the king can't
go to G7 because the bishop protects the
G7 Square can't go to H7 because H7 is
occupied
by the H7 Pawn so in this
position when we start again from this
position we're going to put a rook on
the board we give a rook check the
bishop blocks The Rook the bishop is in
what type of a pin Charlie absolute pin
an absolute pin so what that means is is
that whenever a piece is pinned to a
King the piece absolutely can cannot
move so when we played this move Bishop
to
H6 normally speaking black might try to
take our Bishop he absolutely cannot do
that
because
Charlie attacks the king so the bishop
can't move and the move Rook takes
f8 is impossible to stop I felt
physically helpless Charlie I think they
might be like Toop
a rook A1
check otherwise it would be a back
ranked Checkmate and white would lose
the game King to G2 now we could give
one more check if we like that after
King takes once again this threat of
Rook takes f8 check and mate is
Unstoppable so what I tried to do when I
was a kid is I was looking for all of
these checkmating patterns and I was
thinking to myself if I could list a
whole arsenal of checkmating patterns I
would uh become better and
better another checkmating pattern that
I really really loved you guys are
probably familiar with this one as well
and this is called the two night mate so
this position looks dreadful for for
white right he's down two
Rooks and black is threatening all kinds
of
checkmates what Checkmate is black
threatening black is threatening a
Checkmate Charlie what
Checkmate A1
or1 Rook A1 is Checkmate this Rook on H2
covers all of the squares along the
second Rank and White's King is in check
this Rook is also threatening Rook to H1
as Charlie said and again it's Checkmate
so this was another pattern that I put
in my
Arsenal so white
is does white have to resign it's white
to play can white save the
game can he yeah King G1 King to G1 but
then for example say Knight to G6 and
eventually the two Rooks are going to
win the
game so we need a better move young man
yes Knight E7
check well the black king can't go to F7
that square is protected by this Knight
on E5 I have to go King h8 young man in
the blue
Knight
F7 isn't that a pretty Checkmate the
Knight on F7 attacks The King The King
cannot go to G8 because that Knight on
E7 attacks that
square black is in Checkmate so this was
another checkmating
pattern how about this
one white to move move and Checkmate
Charlie
night Knight C8 to E7 check and mate do
you see that pattern this Knight on G6
attacks the h8 square as well as the f8
square so Black's King cannot go to
either Square this Knight on E7 puts the
knight in check this Knight can't be
captured check mate so this was
another uh two horsepower Checkmate and
so what I would what I wanted to say
about today's class is I created a whole
arsenal of checkmates and today if we
wanted we could go to my home and I have
scrapbooks woo of uh positions that I
put in my scrapbook and I said these are
important important positions and that I
have to recognize these patterns when
they occur and I would take a book or
magazine usually magazines and
newspapers I cut up I took out the
diagrams I pasted them and then I gave
the the the move the winning move
sometimes on books however since I
didn't want to destroy the books I would
make a copy of the diagram then I would
cut them and put them in so I created an
arsenal all the weapons all the weapons
of checkmating patterns that I could
find you know what I
discovered you know what I discovered I
discovered that there were a lot there
are dozens of checkmating patterns and
all of them were rather unique and
really really interesting so I know that
in your journey to become uh Champions
you're going to have to learn a lot of
the these patterns as well and the more
patterns you know the better you're
going to
[Music]
[Applause]
be